[Music]
a las vegas dog food company that
started during the pandemic is booming
young wolf natural pet foods launched in
november of 2020 strictly online jaren
lucas started the company with his
co-founder professional chef who ran
into some tough times during the last
recession and could no longer afford to
feed his dogs the high-end kibble he'd
been feeding them for years so the two
of them worked on perfecting their
recipes and ingredients with a local vet
and pet nutritionist and now they offer
a soft and chewy kibble as well as a
perfect dog food mix for those pet
owners who prefer to make their own dog
food with these items at home
it's all towards paleo dog food no
fillers and human grade ingredients and
really just trying to create the best
absolute dog food that i would want to
feed my dog and then i'm trying to offer
it to everyone else we're part of the
seven billion dollar shift that's
happening over the next five years in
pet food specifically that's going
towards e-commerce we are just you know
one of the beneficiaries among many of a
larger trend
the entrepreneurs are seeing the
inflation behind the scenes that most
businesses are dealing with right now
product and ingredient prices all rising
now they are looking to expand yum wolf
into physical retail shops at most
well-known pet food stores